[Applause]
finally an attractive guest yes you did
scare us you were screaming like that in
your life you know it was Gordon Ramsay
is under fire after that 2010 clip
resurfaced this week the chef appeared
on The Tonight Show with Jay Leno
alongside Sofia Vergara and he made
several comments throughout the joint
interview that made the Modern Family
star seemed visibly uncomfortable you
seem like you're enjoying that now you
had a whole wedge in your mouth at any
one time yeah you haven't heard of a
knife knife and fork no you need pizza
with a knife and a fork you just pick it
up and stick it in reims even took aim
at Sofia Sun Manolo 19 9 mm what no
lonoa what does it mean no it's just a
Hispanic name so everything needs is a
meaning
oh really yeah correct right I was like
to paint um okay this is my interview
yeah
Twitter users are now slamming the chef
over the resurfaced clip users calling
him awful and disrespectful and another
common teen that Sophia should have
quote had him charged with sexual
assault
neither Ramsey Vergara or Leno have yet
to respond to the clip the et has
reached out to their reps
[Music]